I said no one time in my whole career
and that was because the opponent I was
going to face we had the same circle of
friends like basically his head trainer
was one of my groomsmen in my wedding
Jesus so I was like dude he and I are
gonna understand this yeah we punch each
other in the gym all the time like but
everybody around us is going to be weird
when this is said and done so at first I
said no oh really no the only time in my
life I ever tried to get out of it but
basically you're gonna sit we're going
to shelf you for over here to punish you
yeah oh same thing I mean without saying
it you know oh well we might not get
back to you it's pretty tied up man if
you don't take this opportunity I was
like oh damn so it was like all right
well hey never mind I'll take the fight
you know what I mean like I'm in yeah
Roy yeah I was Roy yeah yeah that's
right